i am so happy we're back after three
years at pride toronto it is so much fun
the energy here is amazing today and
everyone just wants to dance have fun
and celebrate being themselves like that
what more could you ask for that is what
it is all about now listen i'm very
curious what is the one song that gets
you in the mood to go out and party i
think i'd have to say come through
priyanka featuring lemon
it is an iconic track were you surprised
by the success of that but most
especially the success of your first rap
queen
yes i i mean i was very surprised you
know like i we honestly wrote it to have
fun and party and like you know just
like let the world know we wanted to be
those girls who you can hear at the club
and have a good time and i honestly feel
like
the mission was accomplished so well
that's why people like it it's just fun
are we gonna get new lemon music anytime
soon we are getting more lemon music i
have a new feature coming out at the end
of this month so you know i'm the i'm
the nicki minaj of drag apparently
you're gonna come to et canada when that
new feature is coming up i would
absolutely love to love you lemon have
fun today